we are going to spend the rest of this
lecture by looking into an interesting
subclass of Markov chains for which
steady-state convergent exists the class
of birth and death processes so what is
a birth and death process
it's a Markov chain was diagram looks
like this the states of the Markov chain
start from zero and go up to some finite
integer number M and if you are at a
typical state in the middle say I then
next you will either go to the right or
up by one unit or you will go to the
left or down by one unit or you will
stay where you are
and this will happen with the following
transition probabilities here P I I
function of the state here Q I and this
one the remaining one minus P I minus Q
I so it's like keeping track of some
animal population animals get born they
die the assumption here is that at any
point in time either one animal gets
born or one dies or nothing happens
there are no multiple deaths no births
happening at the same time there are
many practical applications where the
structure provides a basic first level
Moll an example of a chain of this kind
was the supermarket counter example that
we discussed before where the states
represented the number of customers in
the queue a customer arrives and the
queue increases by one a customer leaves
and the queue decreases by one or
nothing happens and the queue stay as it
is now in this supermarket example the
peas and the queues were all taken to be
the same across the states but we can
generalize for example the departure
rate Q could be different from state to
state for example with lots of customers
in the queue perhaps the clerk will work
faster such a chain can also be used to
model the spread of disease in
population for example the states could
represent the number of people in a
given population that have the flu one
more person gets the flu the count goes
up one more person gets healed the count
goes down these probabilities in such an
epidemic Mao would certainly depend on
the current state if lots of people
already have the flu the priority that
another person catches it would be
pretty high but if no one has the flu
then the priority that one gets a
transition where someone catches the flu
would be pretty small the rate at which
new people get the disease definitely
depends on how many people already have
it and that motivates cases were those
bees here depend on the state of the
chain there are lots of other
applications for which these special
Markov chains are useful so how do we
study them such a chain consists of a
single a periodic recurrent class and so
as a well-defined to the state behavior
to calculate the steady-state
probability PI of I of a state I you can
write the system of M linear equations
in the PI's that we had discussed before
but this may be cumbersome and in fact
more work than one actually needs to do
there is a very clever shortcut that
applies to birth and death processes and
it's based on the frequency
interpretation that we discussed in the
recent clip to see this let's draw a
line somewhere in the middle of this
chain and focus on the transitions
between this left part and this right
part assume that the line cut through
the middle of two adjacent states I and
I plus one like here and so then you
zoom here and this is the picture of
what you have here so what is the chain
going to do let's say it starts on the
left it's going to move around and at
some point it makes a transition to the
other side going here and that is a
transition
i to i plus one and now once it's on the
right side it's going to move around as
well and then at one point it will come
back to that part again and this is a
transition from i plus 1 to i and so on
and so forth now there is a certain
balance that must be obeyed here the
number of upward transitions through
this line cannot be very different from
the number of downward transition from
this line because if we cross this way
then in order to cross again this way
you will have first to cross down the
other way
you cannot go up one other times here in
that direction and go down here 50 times
if you have gone up one other times it
means that you have gone down 99 100 or
101 but nothing different from that so
the long-term frequency with which
transition of this kind occur has to be
the same as the long-term frequency the
transition of that kind occur or in this
diagram the frequency of that kind has
to be the same as the frequency of that
kind so what are these frequencies we
discussed that before the fraction of
times at which transition of this kind
are observed is the fraction of time
that we happen to be at that state which
is PI of I and out of the terms that we
are in that state the fraction of time
that transitions of that time happen is
P of I so the overall frequency will be
PI I times P of I and with the same
argument this is the frequency with
which transition of that kind our
observed pie I plus 1 times Q I plus 1
since these two frequencies are the same
we get an equation that relates PI of I
to PI of I plus one like this so this is
the frequency that we observed here of
this transition and these are the
frequency of these transitions and they
had to be equal this has a nice form
because it gives us a recursion
if we knew PI I you can calculate pi I
plus 1 a search
so it's a system of equations that's
easier to solve than the original system
of linear equations which represent it
before for a general Markov chain but
how do we get started
if we knew PI of 0 then we can use it to
find PI of 1 then from PI of 1 you can
get PI of 2 by oh 3 etc but we don't
know PI of 0 it's one more unknown it's
an unknown and we need to actually use
the extra normalization conditions that
the Sun of all the P I PI J has to be
equal to 1 and after we use that
normalization condition then we can find
all of the PI by first solving for PI of
0 how this can be written PI 0 plus PI 1
which is PI 0 times spiezio over Q 1
plus PI of 2 which is PI of 1 times P 1
over Q 2 PI of 0 times P 0 times P 1
over q1 times q2 which is PI 2 plus etc
equals 1 so this equation allows us to
find PI of 0 and then we use this
recursion to find PI of 1 PI of 2 pi 3
etc